sie ist 152 mal weiter von uns entfernt
als die erde von der sonne die nasa
sonde voyager 1 nun hat sie hinter der
grenze des sonnensystems mysteriöse
geräusche aufgespürt es handelt sich um
ein monotones summen und brummen was
steckt dahinter
krieg zum science im future geht es
dreimal pro woche spannendes seines
videos abonniert den kanal und
aktivierte glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen es
handelt sich um ein monotones summen im
interstellaren raum was ein us
forschungsteam jetzt in daten der nasa
sonde voyager 1 aufgespürt hat die nasa
sonde voyager 1 ist seit jahren im
interstellaren raum unterwegs und gilt
als eine der größten erfolge der nasa
die aktuelle entdeckung zeigt dass die
sonde auch heute noch wertvolle
forschungsarbeit leisten
doch wer oder was steckt konkret hinter
dem konstanten brummund was verraten uns
diese geräusche über den rand unseres
sonnensystems die spannenden antworten
auf all diese fragen gibt es in diesem
video bereits im jahr 1977 waren die
beiden zwillingssonden voyager 1 und 2
von der erde gestartet seitdem sind die
beiden reisenden wie ihr name sagt also
schon unterwegs das ist wirklich irre
und niemand hätte sich das damals
träumen lassen beide sehen mittlerweile
in einem bereich des weltalls unterwegs
in dem noch niemals zuvor ein objekt das
von menschen erschaffen wurde geflogen
ist zunächst machten sich die reisenden
vorbei an jupiter 1980 flogen sie dann
am saturn vorbei von neun jahren 2012
verließ deutsche 1 das sonnensystem
seitdem ist die sonde im bereich
zwischen den sternen also im sogenannten
interstellaren raum unterwegs dafür muss
zunächst die sogenannten heliopause
passiert werden diese wird oft auch als
grenze unseres sonnensystems bezeichnet
es handelt sich um den bereich bis zu
dem die sonnenwinde und deren
magnetfelder aktiv sind dahinter beginnt
dann laut definition der interstellaren
raum doch in diesem zusammenhang sind
noch viele fragen offen wie formt sich
die heliosphäre wählte agiert das
interstellare plasma mit dem sonnenwind
und wie ist die umgebung der heliosphäre
am rand des sonnensystems gestaltet
steht nur die reise dorthin ist nicht
ohne denn dafür müssten nicht nur
gigantische entfernung überwunden werden
sondern auch die gravitationskraft der
sonne
dazu hatten die deutschen sollten
mehrere string beim manöver durchgeführt
sie haben sich also den planeten im
sonnensystem genähert haben sich von
ihrer gravitation anziehen und
beschleunigen lassen sind aber dann
nicht auf sie zugestürzt sondern sind
ausgewichen haben sich also an ihnen
vorbei geschwungen swing by mandl war
heißt das und insgesamt haben sie für
die ganze mission mehr als 25 jahre
gebraucht im april diesen jahres 2021
was dann soweit und die nasa sonde new
horizons erreichte diesen meilenstein
ebenfalls sie hatte die entfernung
grenze von 50 astronomischen einheiten
überschritten und war zu diesem
zeitpunkt dann mehr als 50 mal so weit
von der sonne entfernt als die erde
künftig zu diesem meilenstein hatte new
horizon dann ihre kamera auf die
position von deutschlands gerichtet so
gelang ihr ein foto des sternenfels in
dem wollte einst ihre wann zieht da
wollte einst zu diesem zeitpunkt rund
151 astronomische einheiten von der
sonne entfernt war
weil sie allerdings selbst für die
scharfen kameraaugen von new horizons in
dieser aufnahme nicht direkt sichtbar
zurück zu ihrer spannenden reise bei
ihrem abschied aus unserem sonnensystem
von neun jahren 2012 konnte die nasa
sonde voyager 1 in bestimmten bereichen
ein mysteriöses phänomen beobachten
interstellaren material drang dabei
ihnen die heliosphäre 1
nach der passage durch die heliopause
gab es extreme turbulenzen vermutlich
ausgelöst durch interaktionen zwischen
sonnenwind und interstellare medium 2018
gelang es dann auch weiter zwei in den
interstellaren raum vorzudringen die
turbulenzen die wolga 1 erfuhr konnten
mit hilfe der messgeräte von baa2 aber
nicht festgestellt werden
dazu lehnert wo lager von der nasa in
navarra die von volta zwei beobachtete
heliopause stabil und dünn im gegensatz
zur instabil und dickeren heliopause die
beute 1 richtwerte die ursache für
diesen unterschied steht noch nicht mit
letzter sicherheit fest die forschenden
vermuten aber dass dies möglicherweise
mit der aktivität der sonne zu tun haben
könnte
denn die heliopause wurde von ba1
während eines minimums im
waren aktivitätszyklus passieren bei
voyager 2 fand die passage nah am
maximum des zyklus stadt mittlerweile
ist es fast 23 milliarden kilometer von
der erde entfernt zum vergleich das es
152 mal weiter als die erde von der
sonne unterwegs ist sie mit
unglaublichen 17 kilometern pro sekunde
bis ihre signale die forschungsteams
hier auf der erde erreichen braucht es
21 stunden nach einem jahr ihre reise im
interstellaren raum wurden dann erste
daten ausgewertet eine der spannenden
erkenntnisse die die beiden sonden
ermöglicht haben die heliosphäre scheint
zumindest auf einer seite eine
symmetrische kugelform aufzuweisen diese
rückschlüsse ziehen die forschungsteams
aus der tatsache dass beide raum sondern
die grenze der heliosphäre in fast
gleicher distanz passiert haben beim
wollte einst waren es etwa 121
astronomische einheiten beider zwei rund
119 mit dem griff der astronomischen
einheit wird der mittlere abstand der
erde von der sonne bezeichnet klar ist
beide sonden haben dieselbe halbkugel
der heliosphäre durchquert und diese
schräg in flugrichtung unseres
sonnensystems verlassen
damit wird aber auch eine annahme
widerlegt von der fachleute lange zeit
aus ging nämlich dass der sonnenwind
immer weiter abnimmt je weiter man in
den interstellaren raum kommt
stattdessen zeigen deutsche 1 und 2
dass es dort eine ausgeprägte grenzen
geht also quasi einen scharfen übergang
zum lokalen inter-star medi und super
spannend auch die folgende erkenntnis im
lokalen interstellaren medium liegen die
temperaturen bei achtung 30.000 bis
50.000 grad celsius und das übertrifft
noch einmal alle erwartungen der
fachleute die bislang von 15 bis 30 1000
grad celsius ausgegangen waren
möglicherweise manövriert die
heliosphäre eine art bugwelle vor sich
her durch das interstellare medium denn
das sonnensystem fliegt ja durch dieses
interstellare medium allerdings gibt es
da draußen so wenige atome dass die hohe
temperatur keinen einfluss auf die
sonden hat und jetzt eben eine neue
spektakuläre entdeckung diese gelangen
einem us forschungsteam bei der
auswertung von daten die deutsche 14
erde geschickt
ein schwaches anhaltendes monotones
summen dass ich auf einem sehr engen
frequenzbereich beschränkt es stammt
nach angaben der wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler von interstellarem
gas dazu sagt die wissenschaftlerin
steller cocker wir entdeckten ein
schwaches anhaltendes summen von
interstellarem gas aber was verursacht
ist beim antritt von deutschlands in den
interstellaren raum hatten die
messgeräte störung im gas gemessen
die höchstwahrscheinlich von den sonnen
wind erzeugt wurden doch darin versteckt
ein gleichmäßiges summen dazu schreibt
das forschungsteam der aktuellen studie
das interstellare medium ist wie ein
ruhiger oder sanfter regen im falle
eines sonnen ausbruchs ist es so als
würde man einen blitzschlag in einem
gewitter erkennt bevor es wieder sanft
regnet gemessen wurde das monotone
brummen des interstellaren gases mit
einem der vier instrumente an bord von
heute 1 das noch aktiv ist das
sogenannte plasma wave systems die
wissenschaftler ein wissenschaftler
schließen daraus dass das gas mehr
niederschwellige aktivität aufweist als
man bislang angenommen hatte zudem
ermöglicht dieses hintergrund signal den
fachleuten außerdem messungen an dem gas
vorzunehmen und zwar selbst dann wenn
die sonne dort gerade nicht für
turbulenzen sorgt heißt also im klartext
um interstellare plasma zu messen ist
kein besonderes ereignis der sonne
notwendig dazu sagt die forscherin
camisha thaci die an der aktuellen
studie beteiligt war
wir hatten noch nie die gelegenheit die
dichte des clusters auszuwerten
jetzt wissen wir dass wir kein
zufälliges ereignis im zusammenhang mit
der sonne benötigen um interstellar das
plasma zu messen
das interstellare medium kann man sich
demnach also vorstellen wie einen
leichten sommer regen der aber immer
wieder von einem gewitter unterbrochen
wird nämlich dann wenn sonnenwind das
interstellare medium durchwühlt das
forschungsteam selbst ist von dem
ergebnis positiv überrascht zitat aus
wissenschaftlicher sicht ist das
ergebnis eine wahre meisterleistung die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
sind optimistisch dass ihnen die neuen
erkenntnisse die weitere forschung in
diesem zusammenhang leichter machen wird
zeitnah wollen sie beispielsweise die
örtliche verteilung von plasma bestimmen
und zwar unabhängig eben von dem was die
sonne gerade macht doch langsam geht
auch den beiden nasa soll
energie aus fachleute gehen davon aus
dass die radioaktiven batterien der
sonden noch etwa fünf jahre reichen
werden dazu der planetenforscher edward
stone als die beiden bäume charts
gestartet wurden war das weltraum
zeitalter erst 20 jahre alt niemand hat
erwartet dass sie 40 jahre halten würde
nasa sonde voyager 2 spielt mysteriöse
magnetwand auf anklicken hier anschauen
und abonnieren ab so super spannendes
video bis dann bleibt dran